yeah it's like they say everything comes
in threes all right there's a number of
things that have happened in fairly
rapid succession and I don't have the
time to do videos on all of them so I'm
going to do what I'm calling a grab bag
and this is something that I'll probably
do again on occasions where I don't have
time to make individual videos or maybe
a bunch of things happen that don't
really warrant an entire video on their
own in this case the stuff I'm going to
be talking about are the new trailers
for ant-man Terminator Genisys and also
was going on with Wonder Woman I'll
start with a new ant-man trailer what
everybody has been saying is true it's
better than the last one does that mean
it's actually good yeah the thing is
what is the big improvement is there's a
much heavier emphasis on humor which is
something the first one was really like
in that first trailer really just had
the one joke at the very end and it was
too little too late the thing is even
though the balance is better I don't
think it's quite right yet because
really up until that gag at the end with
the thomas the train engine pretty much
mostly emphasis had been on action there
have been one or two jokes but there's
always been jokes in Marvel movies there
wasn't enough to communicate that this
was actually a comedic piece and I
really think that's the emphasis they
need to be putting on this a bit like
what they did with the early trailers
for guardians of the galaxy they really
sold us on these characters and and the
humor and the outlandishness of this
premise and just buying into how
ridiculous it wasn't there tiptoeing
into that with am and what I really
think they should be going whole hog
most of the trailer they're still trying
to sell us in the action we know Marvel
can do action i don't think anyone
questioned whether or not the action was
gonna work that's not the part they need
to sell some they need to tell us that
the tone is going to be fun and there
are hints of that but i don't think
there's enough of it the other trailer
that came out was the new trailer for
terminator genisys and it is completely
undone the interest that the last
trailer managed to garner from me the
previous trailer actually did get my
interest piqued because i saw that they
were dealing with alternate timelines
and seeing how it both related to but
changed what we'd already seen i was
interested i wanted to see the movie and
now i'm gonna spoiler warning 1 i'm
about to say cuz it's exactly what the
tray
should have done they've now let slip
that John Connor himself is actually the
villain of the piece and not only that
make you very clear in the TRO that it
is John Connor somehow modified with
machinery this is not a terminator
pretending to be John Connor it is him
something has gone wrong with him now
honestly I think we want to know that I
personally was already sold it was
prepared to see the movie they then
oversold and as far as I'm concerned
there's no way this thing has any tricks
left in the bag it completely tipped his
hands there's no more aces up its sleeve
I now it's just a question of well how
did that happen I don't care how it
happened but it would have surprised the
heck out of me if I gone in not knowing
that was gonna happen now it's like all
you can do is show me the nuts and bolts
and logistics of how this actually plays
out and that's nowhere near as
interesting as the set up that could
have gone any number of ways and
obviously what an interesting way that's
the [ __ ] of this it's not a bad idea
and it could work but I would have loved
it if I discovered it in the theater now
I I'm gonna have to sit and mull it over
and live with it and have my own ideas
for so long that there's no way this is
going to be interesting by the time I
see it if I see it finally won a woman
lost its director michelle mclaren and
the exact reason for that is the general
generic statement creative differences
now there's some weird stories coming
out about that but it does seem to be
that this was a pretty clear creative
divide a sounds like her in the studio
couldn't even agree on what time period
to set this movie in but I've no doubt
that right now Warner Brothers is
scrambling and scrambling fast because
PR if nothing else they need to find
another director and another female
director and that's not me Sehwag in my
finger at them it must be a female
director but the fact that they had a
female director honor if she bails
because she's not agreeing with what
they want to do and they bring in a
generic male action kind of director
that's just gonna look really bad so I
don't really have any names to float I
don't know who they'll go for I know
Michelle Maclaren wasn't the only one
they were looking at so maybe they'll go
to one of the others they talked to at
the time I don't know but it's not a
sign it just shows more that DC and
Warner Brothers don't really have a hand
whole what it is they're trying to do
certainly not the way Marvel does and in
fact Marvel has had a very tight grip on
everything from the beginning and
they've been the only time they've lost
the director was Edgar Wright it took
them quite a while the very end of phase
two before they lost a director and DC
right out the gate its first wave of
films and one of its biggest names I
mean hopefully you will be able to tell
if the final product the creative team
had a change over but right now it just
doesn't look good so I guess I said grab
bag for right now you got thoughts on
any of the stuff that I've talked about
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it until
next time this council is adjourned